bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre nouvelle émission
consacrée à la culture
alors je suis ravi de vous retrouver et
de vous accompagner tout au long de
cette saison à la découverte de lieux
d'événements d'artistes qui font la
richesse de notre territoire
tout d'abord la rentrée culturelle c'est
maintenant et c'est dans le kiosque la
rentrée voici par bouc finement voici le
programme de cette édition le festival
pop rock coup d'état revient pour sa
deuxième édition à mort fans les 6 et 7
septembre
sergent garcia eiffel barioz libre et
jennifer ou encore axelle red
une affiche qui promet de réunir le plus
grand nom dans une ambiance familiale
nous en reparlons dans quelques instants
avec nos invités à guyancourt la maison
de la poésie démarre sa rentrée jacques
fournier son directeur nous livre les
faits marquants et les nouveautés de
cette saison
amateurs de rock et de métal retenait
ses date du 10 au 12 octobre prochain le
festival food rock ouvre ses portes à
l'estaminet de manille les amours
guillaume le tocard au micro de nicolas
gervais nous donne tout les détails pour
l'heure revenons sur le festival qui
marque cette rentrée le festival coup
d'état donc pour en parler nous recevons
en plateau gilles costard dans soir donc
vous êtes le trésorier de l'association
coup d'état photophone consiste costard
ou le dit mais vous êtes frère c'est ça
et vous êtes le président de
l'association plutôt feu à vos côtés
javier blanco
bonsoir bonsoir vous représentez un des
groupes locaux qui sera présent sur ce
festival le groupe mario libre est
exactement
alors tout d'abord je m'adresse à vous
francis cette année on a une affiche
plutôt riches plutôt mixte alors j'ai
donné des noms comme ça j'ai évoqué tout
à l'heure on a sergent garcia eiffel
poni hoax
zut
pour les plus jeunes barioz libre et on
l'évoquait encore jennifer accès l'aide
roseraie milliards la louise alors
plutôt mixte parce que c'est à la fois
homme femme et mixtes également parce qu
on a donc des groupes locaux et des
artistes internationaux une
nationalement reconnue au niveau du
festival ce qu'on voulait surtout à la
basse et promouvoir la scène locale et
donc c'est pour ça qu'en programme et on
met un mix donc avec des artistes locaux
et des artistes reconnus au niveau
national et puis la petite chose pour
les histoires des de la soirée
sensuelles
la nouveauté cette année j'ai chaoui
arcep ta façon nouveauté ce qui s'est
passé c'est un concours de circonstances
c'est que la dernière on avait une
programmation avec des hommes et on se
dise il n'y a pas que les hommes qui
représentent leur rock en france là où
la musique est donc dès le départ de la
formation on a réfléchi avant de
formation avec des femmes et puis
finalement en forme mesure commenté la
programmation s'est aperçu qu'on pouvait
complètement monter une soirée 100%
féminine où les femmes prenaient très
noir sur le rocher justement ces
artistes et ben on avait travaillé avec
un détourneur déjà avec le groupe de
kiev n
et puis on est derrière et puis sur un
coup de fil voilà j'ai demandé à
l'artiste était disponible
c'est là qu'il m'a parlé de rose et
d'axelle red
et puis on voit là un guide et vient
finalement d'un petit collectif comme
toute femme tout à fait et puis c'est
monte au fur et à mesure et puis après
thomas
qui est le programmateur avec moi dit
tiens j'ai du grand hamster triste qui
vient de cergy voilà s'appellerait milla
est intéressant et puis au fur et à
mesure pourquoi on sait pas une soirée
100% féminine et voilà c'est parti
et puis après le petit ami ça veut dire
que les femmes vont prendre le pouvoir
ce bout de terre tout à fait voilà toute
une soirée où les femmes sont au pouvoir
voilà et et puis pour finir là sur
jenifer voilà c'est peut noter que
jenifer c'est important parce que c'est
sa dernière date tout à fait fondé de
france voilà après le jour à puer va
rentrer va repartir sur the voice et
puis peut-être un prochain album et puis
mais c'est sa dernière date en tout cas
en ile-de-france alors moi je vous
propose bac on regarde un teaser qui
nous donnera l'étendue justement des
groupes présents
comme ça
gilles costard dites-moi ce festival
coup d'état s'adresse plutôt à quel type
de public un coup d'état se veut un
festival pour tous donc avec la
programmation nous avons vu précédemment
qui est très éclectique donc ça festival
familial
d'une part un festival qui s'adresse aux
personnes qui aiment aussi le rock qui
aiment à pascal vendredi c'est tellement
plus rock une salle à tout à ferhat et
le samedi c'est plus pop plutôt pop
effectivement et puis nous cette année
nous accueillons enfin comme l'année
dernière nous accueillons les personnes
également à mobilité réduite
alors nous mettons en place cette année
à une estrade de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent avoir une vision surélevée
enfin être surélevé pendant une
meilleure vision de la scène qui elle
mène d'ailleurs est également surélevée
nous accueillons les cyclistes puisque
cette année nous avons pensé en tant que
festival festival vert à mettre en place
un
est partie alors qu'ils n'avaient l'eau
voilà ce qu'est dans le cadre de ce
festival vert donc c'est quelque chose
que vous faisiez déjà l'année dernière
qu'est-ce que vous développez également
autour de ses actions alors deux choses
qui des toilettes sèches par exemple
évidemment le festival est nettoyé et
nous trions les déchets qu'est-ce que
j'oublie de la zec occupent de façon
elle n'a pas retrouvé dans les stations
n'ont pas retrouvé des gobelets sur le
site dont j'ai des gobelets qui sont qui
sont récupérés ensuite et notre
fournisseur les laver puis donc ça évite
de dépenser enfin ça évite surtout de
d'avoir des gobelets en plastique qui
ensuite sont jetés du tri sélectif et du
tri sélectif
alors je parlais de restauration parce
que cette année vous mettez en place un
espace aussi dédié à cette restauration
qu'il n'y avait pas avant
alors si ces derniers arrivaient quand
même n'est ce pas enfin du moins il y
avait des ambulants mais effectivement
cette année il y a
ah si donc nos festivaliers pourront se
restaurer confortablement
nous avons mis en place des bancs des
tables
c'était tout à fait équilibré différents
types de restauration bien évidemment ok
alors javier javier blanco vous vous
représentez barioz libre et donc c'est
un groupe vous êtes yves in war 3
dites-nous déjà juste comme ça je veux
trop dans quelle est la signification de
ce ballet horrible alors balyo libre est
en fait si on traduit littéralement ça
veut dire quartier libre donc d'une part
c'est le quartier libre donc le temps
dont on dispose pour faire des choses
sympas en l'occurrence répéter faire des
concerts et cetera mais ça veut aussi un
symbole est aussi un quartier qui
seraient libres donc un quartier on a
tendance à stigmatiser les quartiers
la légende un quartier main peut faire
exactement la même chose que ceux des
villes importantes que ceux qui habitent
à la campagne on est libre voilà donc ça
ça donnait une sorte de saint souffler
une sorte de vent de liberté dans qu'on
trouve peut-être dans notre musique
aussi et on trouvait que ça avait de
l'impact on aimait bien ces deux mots
barillot libre et alors c'est en
espagnol
la plupart de vos chansons sont écrites
en espagnol
comment cet espagnol ben oui je suis
espagnol l'espagne c'est vrai que je
baigne dedans depuis tout petit parce
que je l'espagnol et parents sont
espagnols mon frère d'espagnols qui fait
partie du groupe et on aime bien cette
façon de j'ai pas mal de faciliter
écrire les textes en espagnol ça me
parle beaucoup mais plus ça va plus on
avance plus on écrit en français
également plus on adapte cet autre chose
mais ça commence à nous plaire vraiment
bon comment on peut définir justement
votre style musical
le style musical c'est très rock on a en
a une tendance de plus en plus rock avec
un côté un peu plat non et très
mélodieux c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
des choses qu'ils soient dynamiques
qu'ils soient énergique mais qui sont en
même temps planante et qui qu'ils
aillent qu'ils aillent à l'intérieur des
gens on essaie de toucher la sensibilité
des gens à travers la musique à travers
les textes pour ceux qui les comprennent
et à l'aller thème qu'est-ce que vous
abordez
ces vagues il ya beaucoup de choses
c'est surtout une sorte d'introspection
parfois des gens on essaie de d'analyser
un peu les comportements des gens et pas
seulement les comportements amoureux
mais aussi les relations familiales les
choses qui vont qui ne vont pas dans la
vie c'est la réflexion plutôt des
réflexions ce ne sont pas des histoires
concrètes qui vont parler de quelqu'un
10 avril le matin qui va il peut ya voir
ça mais c'est surtout plutôt une
réflexion d'ordre global qui s'adapte
davantage à la musique aussi avec les
envolées musicales et cetera donc c'est
un peu ce style toujours rock et parfois
même festif donc c'est un concert qu'on
le voit ça donc c'est voilà vous êtes
vous voulez vraiment on n'est pas bon
qu'on là ils vont mais bon vraiment
partout mais on live un live
exceptionnel voilà alors les places
francis on peut les trouver encore oui
bien sûr vous savez donc alors dans tous
les lieux habituels donc la fnac
et puis bien créé en ligne tout à fait
digitick with event par par notre site
aussi également vous pouvez ya un lien
au chant carrefour leclerc tous les
points de vente habituels même certains
bureaux de tabac vendent ce qu'ils ont
ils se méfient pour rappel le prix des
places alors en prévente simplement
cheikh où il toutes les sauces grasses
que ça ne me sort avant d'envié et
samedi donc à peu près à les taxer 22 01
soir 32 et pour les deux soirs tout à
fait prêt ça c'est pour
le tarif normal on fait aussi partager
pour étudiants devant emploi famille
nombreuse et là c'est 16 euros pour un
soir et 26 pour les deux fois et c'est
gratuit pour les moins de 12 ans tout à
fait donc c'est vraiment un festival
familial
oui et puis aussi toutes les personnes à
mobilité réduite qui viennent sur
festival l'accompagnateur bien sûr et
gratuit d'accord écoutez merci beaucoup
on vous souhaite un très bon festival on
rappelle donc les dates c'est ça
commence vendredi soir jusque samedi
soir deux soirs de festivités donc à
maurepas
merci à tous les trois des donneurs dont
la maison de la poésie donc à guyancourt
démarre sa nouvelle saison nous avons
rencontré jacques fournier son directeur
qui va nous relever route nous révéler
pardon les faits marquants et toutes les
nouveautés à découvrir
jacques fournier bonjour bonjour
donc vous ne recevez à la maison de la
poésie pour nous parler la nouvelle
programmation pour cette nouvelle saison
2013 2014 au douzième saison
quels sont les faits marquants alors il
ya les rendez vous que l'on va retrouver
depuis quelques années déjà le lancement
de saison le 21 septembre avec une
objection un peu particulière qui sera
le un bal politique
le festival poésie flynn la semaine des
poètes avec le soutien du conseil
général donc là c'est la 10e édition
donc on marque le coup en invitant tous
les lauréats des prix poésie vinet
poésie ville des collégiens donc sur
tout le département pendant dix jours et
à la maison la positionnement rendra
hommage à jean rousselot qui aura 100
ans qui aurait eu 100 ans cette année
le vide qui est décédé et pierre garnier
qui ne peut pas venir puisqu'il est
assez âgée voilà mais tout le reste se
passera dans tout le département on est
à mantes-la-jolie on sera la ferme de
bel ébat on sera chevreuse etc
c'est une collaboration avec habituel
avec des dizaines de collaborateurs des
communes
on rendra hommage à jean cocteau pour le
cinquantenaire anniversaire de sa
disparition puisque on fera le avec une
lecture que j'ai proposé par la
compagnie pm dv le lancement des
manifestations de maisons laffitte aux
aînés qui me que cocteau hommage à
cocteau donc sûr c'est avec cette
lecture le 12 octobre
voilà donc on est vraiment un petit peu
partout mais ça c'est une habitude dans
les habitudes ont ainsi le printemps des
poètes voilà le printemps des poètes
c'est une année c'est une année perd
donc ses seins je dirais un simple
printemps des poètes mais qui commencera
quand même le 3 mars se terminera le
doit être le 29 ou 30 mar je ne sais
même plus tellement il y aura deux
manifestations quasiment tous les ans un
jour sur deux on sera on aura des
lectures des rencontres des spectacles
là encore une grosse collaboration avec
les partenaires du territoire de saint
quentin cette fois ci la ferme de bel
ébat la scène nationale les médiathèques
etc
donc voilà on essaye d'être encore et
toujours présent sur ce territoire on
l'investît ont fait en sorte de
présenter la poésie là où et sa place
c'est-à-dire partout
quelle est la programmation pour le
jeune public
alors pour le jeune public on a des
spectacles qui sont intégrés dans la
programmation jeune public de saint
quentin en yvelines
alors il y aura on va en fait être
associé au festival du conte en eau en
décembre avec une création de bernard
moreau on va suivre le petit poucet mais
à sa manière de manière un peu plus
peut-être plus difficile plus dure que
on l'entend habituellement peut-être un
plus un retour aux sources du petit
poucet qui est un texte très difficile
en réalité très violent voilà puis on
s'associe avec la firme de belles et
basse sur sa journée poésie de mars avec
des spectacles jeune public dans la
journée différentes choses qui seront
proposées dont lucienne deschamps et
allons enfants de la poésie qu'on a fait
créer à manier les hameaux voilà il y
aura aussi une collaboration avec
odyssée 78 la biennale de théâtre il ya
un projet avec noémie boutin au
violoncelle de d'entrer dans une poésie
ludique sonore avec de la musique donc
on va proposer le spectacle ici voilà et
il y aura aussi on va proposer mais pour
des plus grands une découverte de pablo
picasso poète à travers le travail qu'a
fait bernard ascal qui vient d'avoir un
coup de coeur de l'académie charles cros
pour le merveilleux ouvrage cd + livret
+ livre sur la poésie de pablo picasso
que peu de gens connaissent alors la
poésie sonore on va l'entendre aussi ce
qu'on appelle la positionnant puisqu'on
va accueillir jean marc heureuse avec
une collaboration avec l'université de
saint quentin en yvelines dans le cadre
d'un colloque sur la poésie or le livre
on va voir valérie rouzeau qui travaille
beaucoup l'oralité
on va voir comme ça d on va
retrouvez frédéric volle michaud pour le
troisième volet d' sont ainsi des bribes
cette fois ci avec des textes de jacques
darras d'homère et de dante
donc voilà tout un travail sur l'oralité
sur la manière de prendre la parole par
le poème pour la transmettre cette année
monique de recel est aussi à l'honneur
alors monique dorcel oui parce que c'est
une grande dame du théâtre et de la
poésie qui a animé pendant créé à
bruxelles le théâtre poème qui est un
lieu mythique qui cake à la voile a
quitté la direction il ya peu de temps
et c'est une dame cac qui connaît des
centaines de textes par coeur qui a mis
en scène tous les poètes contemporains
et les anciens aussi une manière de
rendre de remercier une grande dame du
théâtre et de la poésie c'est vraiment
pour la remercier pour ce qu'elle fait
parce que je crois qu'elle fait partie
de ces gens qui m'ont donné le goût à la
poésie mais aussi à la mi alalala 10h la
monstration du poème sur la scène telle
qu elle le fait elle même on a aussi
quelques nouveautés notamment les jeudis
de bérénice ah oui ça c'est alors
bérénice les un peu connue des gens la
maison la poésie parce qu'elle a déjà
intervenu ici les musiciennes c'est
bérénice catala et les violoncellistes
la vie de versailles
c'est une merveilleuse du mans series
que j'ai découvert il ya quelques années
on on a commencé à collaborer sur le
festival poésie yvelines
et puis voilà je lui ai lancé un pari je
lui ai dit écoute j'ai envie que tu
entres dans la programmation mais en
étant programmatrice c'est à dire je te
propose un jeudi par mois de donner
rendez vous aux habitants de saint
quentin en yvelines et des environs ici
à la maison de la poésie avec ton choix
de musiciens et ton choix d'auteurs de
comédiens ou de poètes invités
donc une fois par mois le deuxième jeudi
du mois à partir de janvier
même le 8 mai puisqu'au mais sa tombe
voilà même un jour férié on prend le
risque
elle a invité
un musicien ou une musicienne un
comédien une comédienne favola elle a
fait sa programmation
c'est un pari tu les fais elle a relevé
le défi et je trouve ça merveilleux de
travailler avec elle à l'occasion des 50
ans du discours prononcés par martin
luther king la maison de la poésie
accueille l'exposition de six vegas tôt
à yahvé dream une exposition plutôt une
installation sous forme sonore
disponible donc jusqu'au 18 octobre
le 28 août 1963 résonnaient à washington
le célèbre à have a dream cinquante ans
plus tard à guyancourt la maison de la
poésie rend hommage au discours de
martin luther king à son rêve éveillé
d'un monde meilleur
elle accueille jusqu'au 18 octobre une
exposition sous forme d'installations
sonores originales et participative
on a demandé à sylvie gastaud une
dentellière du son de collecter des sens
un petit peu partout ce qu'elle a fait
merveilleusement puisqu'elle a demandé à
des poètes et à des gens de lire le
texte de martin luther king dans une
vingtaine de langues différentes dont du
gaulois par exemple du grec l'espagnol
de l'arabe et caetera et on va retrouver
tout ça plus où le travail
d'enregistrement qu'elle a pu faire dans
les collèges et les lycées les écoles
tout au long de l'année sur la
thématique du rêve et surtout du rêve
qui correspond à nos nos missions c'est
à dire montrer que la poésie est un une
parole d'unité une parole de 2,2 de paix
une parole de réconciliation c'est un
vrai pouvoir civique que possède la
poésie et donc elle le met en avant
objets d'époque band archives poèmes
traduction documentaire autant
d'éléments qui ponctuent la découverte
du visiteur
ce qui m'intéressait par dessus tout
dans ce discours c'était les langues
c'était de faire converser les peuples
de travailler sur les coûte entre les
langues entre les peuples où ma femme
aime des langues avec les accents je
suis parti avec l'idée d'enregistrer le
discours dans l'indre l'indifférente en
écho à l'exposition sylvie gazeau
présentera le 13 septembre au cours
d'une performance sonore et musicale le
dream de babel une proposition du
discours de martin luther king traduite
différentes langues et accompagné au
saxophone pour clôturer notre édition
retour à la musique
il paraît qu'un magny les hameaux se
prépare un festival festival food rock
alors de quoi s'agit-il notre
chroniqueur nicolas gervais a mené
l'investigation ans les quotas bonjour
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du
festival food rock c'est du 10 au 12
octobre à l'estaminet à magny les
hameaux mais prenez date tout de suite
car c'est le festival rock de la rentrée
et c'est guillaume l'autocar qui nous en
parle tout de suite c'était encore en
vacances
pas du tout mais alors là pas du tout
aller à la plage aux bleus l'esprit
c'est le rock temps dans toutes ses
dents toute signature quoi notre
ambition c'est de ces des traces
éclectique donc on va on peut avoir du
fun qu'on peut avoir du rock assez pop
on va aller jusqu'au métal les deux
premières éditions étaient assez métal
puisqu'on avait beaucoup de connexions
dans ce milieu là et puis cette année on
s'ouvre un peu plus on a quelques
exclure
m
c'est normal et kehl
en 2013 ces trois jours les années
précédentes on avait qu'une seule
journée
la première journée le jeudi on va avoir
toute une conférence sur les musiques
actuelles
donc ça c'est en partenariat toujours
avec l'estaminet le vendredi on va voir
là on va vraiment rentré dans le vif du
sujet avec des concerts avec quatre
groupes
donc ça va commencer sur les inventeurs
18 heures avec un premier groupe très
local qui se proposent qui a qui
cartonne pas mal qui a gagné pas mal de
concours au talent tour on va voir
abinaya un groupe pareil de la région
parisienne donc et plutôt métal tribales
avec pas mal de père qu on va avoir une
exclusivité qui va être un groupe
américain qui est grec à la base mais
qui cartonne aux états unis depuis
depuis deux ans qui est barb wire dolls
donc un groupe de punk produit par steve
albini donc qui est très connu pour
nirvana donc là dessus on a en a comme
on a des connexions à los angeles on a
pu décrocher deux groupes l'un qui
seront détruits en france
et on finira sur deportivo le vendredi
soir donc en apothéose avec ce groupe
finalement assez assez connu dans quoi
quand j'ai mai
rejoints
et le samedi donc là on va avoir 7
groupes donc grosse journée on commence
sur les coups de 16 heures
on va avoir alors on est une formule où
on a un groupe qui est dans le bar qui
anime en fondant sur les changements de
plateau entre les groupes et on aura
pour commencer thor the raven d'un
groupe de bordeaux qui qui est qui est
très très bon très éclectique toujours
un peu dans le métal mais avec des
beaucoup de variations
on aura à man you qui a un groupe pareil
de la région qui va jouer plutôt un
métal mélodique instrumental novels un
groupe qui monte aussi très fort qu'elle
jouait pas mal aux états unis un groupe
du mans on aura après dans les têtes
d'affiché ce qu'on appelle donc les
groupes un peu plus un peu plus connus
on va avoir
séveno x un groupe de stoner qui jouait
le fest qui a joué au ffs parlons mois
de juin
/
on va voir bukowski qui est pareil à et
commence à être assez est même plutôt
très connu sur la scène métal
et on finira par the hyènes qui est les
anciens noir désir groupe finalement
lancé par albert dupontel pour pour dans
le cadre d'un de ses films et donc qui
va nous clôturer le festival du samedi
de manière très forte en aucun doute là
dessus
ouais
j'ai commis mais monsieur est important
dans ce monde assurément
côté cause
je
c'est un festival qu'on veut très humain
très festif et la particularité de nos
festivals c'est que on est dans de très
beaux locaux mais on a une proximité
avec les groupes et donc tout au long
d'une journée en fait les artistes
viennent participent sont dans la salle
sont dans le bar et que cela
mais voilà vous les studios à vous
cognacq jay pète le guen tu m'envoies
sur aurélien s'il te plait merci nicolas
donc que nous retrouveront d'ailleurs
chaque semaine dans le kiosque
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivi
donc sur téléfilm je vous retrouve
mercredi prochain en direct à 18h30
habito